It's important to note that geolocation isn't just about your
position on a map, it's also incredibly useful for location
aware presentation. For example, for a website for a chain
of stores, right in the front page you can show what
the closest store is to the user's current location. And
what their current hours are. This is almost certainly exactly
what the user was looking for when they navigated to
your app. You don't have to bury it under a store
locator link. You can certainly do lots of other things with geolocation,
too. You could use geolocation to implement a geocaching game, for example,
or to do augmented reality. But Geolocation has many uses that just
make the user experience better by
better integrating with the real world environment.